[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci pour pour cet accueil
chaleureux merci pour tes mots françois
monsieur le premier ministre jan
fischer françois monsieur le président
du modem mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires
les parlementaires européens notamment
que je salue particulièrement chers amis
aujourd'hui je voulais partager quelques
idées avec boucle avec vous qui sont
importantes parce qu'elles sont
importantes mais en tout cas
elles ont du sens pour moi
je voulais d'abord vous dire que je sais
à quel point marielle vous manque et je
voulais vous dire que le moment beaucoup
à moi aussi
j'aurais aimé démarré avec quelques
plaisanteries bretonne on m'a dit que
richard ferrand s'étaient livrés à
l'exercice au yen
mais les mouches breton n'est pas très
facile à pratiquer pour les non
résidents et d'ailleurs il n'est pas
très facile à définir
si je me laissais je dirais que ce sont
des traits d'esprit que seul richard
ferrand et les sociaux démocrates
peuvent comprendre ce qui dans ce moment
n'est pas totalement sans signification
j'ai compris que mon discours est déjà
très politique
je suis heureux d'être à nouveau à
guidel devant vous aujourd'hui merci les
avoir invités françois et des nombreux
marcheurs qui ont été parmi vous non des
moindres tout au long du week-end je
suis heureux d'y retrouver le premier
ministre sheikh gens qui n'est pas
fondamentalement un marcheur mais qui en
la matière n'a aucun brevet à recevoir
temps tu avale les kilomètres
tentez déplacements sont nombreux
et ils sont autant d'occasions pour toi
de porter la politique du gouvernement
que tu diriges que tu diriges si bien
aidé en être d'une certaine façon sur
les territoires le gardien du réel merci
pour ceux là cherchant
je disais que je suis heureux d'être à
nouveau à guidel parce que guidel c'est
un point fixe c'est un point de repère
d'une certaine façon dans la vie
politique du pays et la vie politique du
pays a besoin de points de repère guide
est un endroit où on vient et où l'on
revient
c'est un endroit je le disais qu est un
point fixe et où le modem a toujours
démontré la constance et la force de ses
idées et de ses valeurs et je crois que
c'est très important pour ça et que cet
apport à la vie politique du pays il est
très important de la part du modem est
ce que parfois certains appellent de
l'obstination pour ce qu'ils sont et
combat mon cher françois moi je crois
que en réalité ce n'est que la
traduction de l'énergie militante celle
d'un éternel militants et pour ça aussi
je veux qu'ils en soient remerciés
et puis good health est un lieu qui
donne envie de réfléchir
peut-être parce que nous sommes face à
la mer c'est un lieu qui donne envie de
dépasser les crimes des choses et la vie
politique est bien dotée en matière des
crimes mais c'est un lieu qui donne
envie de penser à l'avenir du pays et le
faire en ayant le sens du temps long et
non pas mon cher françois je me rappelle
de cette formidable phrase de vaclav
havel que tu m'as cité un jour celle de
ne pas avoir l'impatience de ceux qui
pour faire pousser les arbres plus vite
leurs tirs sur les feuilles et je crois
que cette phrase à elle dit bien ce que
doit être le sens du temps long dans la
vie politique du pays et je vais vous
dire dans cette rentrée dans ce mois de
septembre nous avons nous majorité
présidentielle
le privilège de pouvoir penser non
seulement au présent notre pays et
devant le premier ministre évidemment
dieu sait qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire dans les prochaines semaines mais
aussi de pouvoir penser à l'avenir du
pays parce que dans cette rentrée
politique nous sommes au fond les seuls
à avoir les idées claires une ligne
politique un leader incontesté et la
volonté de nous rassembler et je crois
que ça c'est suffisamment important est
que ça dénote avec ce que montre deux
oppositions dans cette rentrée politique
de la droite qui s'en remet à un congrès
riquiqui pour choisir son candidat de la
gauche qui n'en finit pas de radicaliser
son propre émiettement et même de
l'extrême droite c'est un fait nouveau
qui est maintenant divisée dans le pays
en réalité dans cette rentrée nous
sommes les seuls à montrer notre envie
de nous rassembler et de nous projeter
pour l'avenir du pays
[Applaudissements]
et pour regarder là où nous voulons
aller ensemble parce que nous avons cet
horizon partager je crois qu'il faut pas
oublier de regarder si l'on veut suivre
le conseil de vaclav havel de là d'où on
vient et nos racines communes
c'est ce que nous avons fait derrière
emmanuel macron ensemble en 2017 et au
fond quelle en était la force
d'abord d'être partie des idées d'abord
d'être partie d'un projet avant de
chercher à rassembler les uns et les
autres avant de chercher à rassembler
les appareils partisans et les appareils
militants le projet d'abord d'avoir dit
à chacun que ce qui importait c'était
pas de là où ils venaient mais là où
nous voulions aller ensemble de pouvoir
réunir des personnalités d'horizons
politiques très différents mais sur la
base d'un projet qui n'a fait en 2007
l'objet d'aucune négociation les jamais
ce moment là on dit viens tel ralliement
contre telle idée contre telle partie du
projet est le constat que nous avons
fait c'est que sur les grands sujets sur
l'europe sur le travail sur la liberté
sur l'humanisme certaine façon la
réalité c'est qu'en 2017 nous étions
d'accord sur tout et c'est ça qui a fait
la force inébranlable de notre projet et
cette méthode au fond ce n'est pas
l'absence d'idées j'entends parler
parfois d'un attrape tout d'un fourre
tout moi je combats et je crois que
toutes les interventions que vous aurez
fait à la tribune ce matin montrent
qu'il ya bien une définition idéologique
de ce que nous pensons ensemble et elle
nous a permis de faire émerger de faire
surgir en 2017 ce grand espace central
dans la vie politique du pays dont
j'affirme qu'il est cet espace celui qui
a la plus grande cohérence idéologique
de tout le champ politique la vie
politique du pays
et cette force là elle nous a permis
de construire une majorité
qui a été rejoint par la suite par nos
amis se d'agir par des sociaux
démocrates qui ont rejoints pour
certains territoires de progrès et puis
par deux premiers ministres edouard
philippe puis jean castex qui ont qu'ils
nous ont rejoints par adhésion je le
crois au projet mais aussi à la méthode
et qui tous les deux ont démontré ont
démontré la valeur d'homme d'état qui
était la leur
et c'est cette clarté dans les idées qui
depuis quatre ans nous a permis de
gouverner ensemble et nous a permis de
travailler toutes les crises que nous
avons connues mais de traverser ces
crises en gardant une boussole en
gardant un cap en ne changeant au fond
jamais de trajectoire sur ce qui est
l'essentiel bien sûr qu'il a fallu
l'agilité pour s'adapter pour faire le
quoi qu'il en coûte mais je veux que
nous soyons tous très conscients qu'au
fond nous n'avons pas dévié
idéologiquement sur le substrat
fondamental de ce qui nous rassemble le
travail l'emploi la protection des
français vous le rappeler encore ce
matin avec de grandes réformes en
matière de santé en matière d'éducation
ce sont peut-être les plus fondamentales
pour l'europe dont nous faisons bouger
les lignes et l'actualité géopolitique
la plus récente montre que nous avons
encore besoin de faire bouger les lignes
en europe et puis aussi pour défendre la
république en la défendant contre toutes
les formes de séparatisme
ça aussi c'est le combat de notre
génération et c'est le combat que le
continuons à mener ensemble
alors au moment où nous devons écrire un
nouveau chapitre
cette méthode gardons là les idées
d'abord et les organisations qui en
découlent par la suite car ce qui se
joue aujourd'hui c'est bien l'avenir du
pays ce sont et c'est ça qui compte les
grands défis qui sont devant nous celui
de la souveraineté française et
européenne celui de la transition
écologique qui va falloir encore
accélérer celui de l'avenir de notre
modèle social que nous devons avoir le
courage de réformer celui de la dette
que nous devrons rembourser celui de la
protection de nos concitoyens que nous
devrons assurer pour ne citer que ceux
là et c'est pourquoi je veux le partager
avec vous mes amis ce matin notre
première responsabilité notre toute
première responsabilité c'est de tout
faire pour permettre le rassemblement le
plus puissant possible derrière le
président de la république et cette
vision commune celle que nous partageons
pour l'élection présidentielle de 2000
22 en tant que mouvement fondateur
mouvement couleurs de la majorité
présidentielle nous devons tout faire
pour faciliter le rassemblement le plus
puissant c'est à dire le plus large
possible et le plus tôt possible
derrière le président de la république
soyons très clairs là dessus parce que
on doit pas s'y tromper cette nouvelle
page dont je parle ça sera certainement
la plus difficile à écrire je vois
beaucoup de commentaires mais je veux
que nous gardions ensemble de cette
facilité qui consisterait à penser déjà
à l'après 2022 à tirer des plans sur la
comète alors que ce combat là il sera
extraordinairement difficile que tous
ceux qui pensent que les sondages
aujourd'hui démontrerait telle ou telle
solidité d'une telle peine socle je
crois que ça serait une folie de le
penser et que nous avons d'abord un
combat à mener ne nous trompons pas de
sens dans les élections je crois qu'il
faut les prendre golborne
alors pour cela rassemblons
rassemblons et bâtissons cette maison
commune dont on parle depuis si
longtemps
vous le savez
je crois que vous le savez vous avez
devant vous un artisan sincère loyal
besogneux du rassemblement et de la
construction de notre maison commune
depuis trois ans j'ai plaidé en plus
tard pour les applaudissements quand on
a réussi
j'ai plaidé à bordeaux amiens ici devant
vous à guidel je le ferai encore avignon
pour que nous bâtissions cette maison
depuis trois ans dans les actes aussi
nous avons travaillé ensemble et je veux
que tous les visages avec qui j'ai
l'habitude de travailler aujourd'hui
jean noël sarah jacqueline patrick les
ministres geneviève nathalie je suis sûr
que j'en oublie les députés repérage
élevé oublié personne parce qu'on a bien
travaillé ensemble on l'a fait dans les
actes malgré les difficultés bien sûr
qui a eu des difficultés
vous n'avez rappeler ici ou là ici quand
on sait pas entendu aux municipales dans
telle ville là où on n'a pas eu le
succès escompté dans les élections
locales bien sûr qu'il ya des
difficultés mais cette énergie là et
cette volonté de bâtir ensemble je crois
que nous en avons fait la démonstration
commune dans les actes et parce que j'y
crois je veux partager avec vous ce que
je perçois comme des exigences qui sont
autant de conditions et de garantie de
réussite de maison commune j'en citerai
4 ce matin la première je n'ai déjà
partager les idées d'abord la communauté
de pensée et les questions
d'organisation qui en découlent nous
sommes assaillis de questions pour
savoir si la forme de cette maison
commune ça doit être une coopérative une
confédération une fédération à parti
unique etc
rassurez vous êtes dit à chacun de se
rassurer nous allons travailler dans les
prochaines semaines à construire la
forme mais aucune affaire de boutiques
d'une certaine façon ne doit jamais
prendre le dessus sur les affaires du
pays et sur le fond ce que nous devons
construire ensemble c'est un principe
simple
la deuxième exigence est de considérer
qu'à partir du coeur historique de notre
majorité du modem et de la république en
marche nous devons poursuivre le travail
d'élargissement de la majorité
soyons très clairs élargir sa veut pas
dire morceaux les l'élargissement ce
n'est pas la balkanisation de notre
majorité présidentielle mais nous devons
faire une place à tous ceux qui
partagent notre vision de la société et
qui ne se reconnaissent plus dans un
paysage politique où l'on avait bien
compris qu'il y avait deux gauches
irréconciliables et nous avons
maintenant devant les yeux le fait que
de droite sont elles aussi rire
irréconciliables alors accueillons le
besoin une place pour tous ceux qui
pensent comme nous
la troisième condition
elle est très importante à mes yeux
c'est de rester fidèle à ce qui fait à
la fois l'originalité mais la force de
notre projet commun c'est-à-dire le
dépassement des clivages entre la droite
et la gauche je trouve quand je lis les
articles
quand je regarde la vie politique il est
débat politique tel qu'il se construit
que beaucoup de force nous ramène de
façon gravitaire au clivage
droite-gauche rêverait au fond de le
réinstaller mais moi je n'ai pas fait en
marche pour me réinscrire à nouveau dans
un clivage entre la droite et la gauche
je pense que ce clivage l'ad-pa plus
opérant aujourd'hui en 2021 ou à la
proche de 2022 qui ne l'était en 2017
alors gardons gardons cela et ne
demandons à personne dans notre majorité
de devoir choisir entre l'aide droite ou
la gauche je serais bien incapable de le
faire la force de notre projet c'est
celui du dépassement du clivage entre la
droite et la gauche
et puis la quatrième exigences mais
françois qui l'expriment très bien et en
des termes que je suis certain que tu
exprimes raïssi mieux que moi c'est de
conserver ce que nous sommes l'identité
de ces forces là vous en avez fait la
démonstration ce matin pour ce qui
concerne le modem et moi devant vous je
suis fier de représenter un mouvement
citoyen un mouvement qui a été au fond
un surgissement citoyens un élan
populaire dans le pays alors gardons
cela dans ce que nous devons inventer
demain gardons les deux pieds dans la
société civile les deux pieds dans le
réel au fond gardons cet élan populaire
je crois que c'est extrêmement important
dans ce que nous devons construire en
sang
[Applaudissements]
alors travaillons c'est ce que nous
allons faire dans les prochaines
semaines vous avez engagé vos instances
nous en parlerons aussi avec les
instances de la république travaillons
et nous réussirons travaillons mais sans
oublier d'agir et je vous propose dès
les prochains jours dès les prochaines
semaines d'aller ensemble sur le terrain
pour porter haut et fort le bilan de
notre majorité ce bilan que nous avons
construit ensemble d'aller dire aux
français que ce quinquennat ça a été un
quinquennat de plus cinq années de plus
pour nos concitoyens eh bien nous avons
un exercice pratique à mener ensemble
faisons le sur les terrains sur le tous
les chemins de france pour aller
convaincre nos concitoyens et bien sûr
agir agir dans l'intérêt du pays agir au
sein du gouvernement agir à l'assemblée
nationale il nous reste tant à faire
jusqu'au dernier quart d'heure de ce
quinquennat mais de cela je suis certain
monsieur le ministre le premier ministre
que tu en parlera mieux que moi je
serais heureux de te cédé la parole mais
avant je vous propose d'écouter françois
bayrou votre président je vous remercie